Optimal, minimal. At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought
to you by freshbooks.
Freshbooks is now the number one cloud
accounting software designed exclusively
for self employed professionals and
used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices, track
your time, and get paid fast,
which basically describes the core needs
of most entrepreneurs and freelancers.
The product was recently relaunched
and rebuilt from the ground up,
focusing on simplicity and speed.
It's an awesome service and many
have you recommended it to me,
which is how they came to be a sponsor.
Now I can't cover all of the many,
many features,
but for example,
you can take pictures of receipts on your
phone using freshbooks ios mobile app
or connect your bank account or credit
card to fresh books and watch your
expenses automatically import
into your account every day.
And if you have any questions whatsoever,
a real live person answers in less than
three rings to help you with all of your
needs. So to claim your 30
day unrestricted free trial,
that means no credit card needed and see
how the all new fresh books can change
your freelancing game.
Go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim
and enter Tim Tim in the how did you hear
about us section that is freshbooks.com
forward slash Tim and then put Tim t I m
in the how did you hear about us section?
This episode is brought
to you by Wealthfront.
Wealthfront is the future
of financial advice.
They become incredibly popular among my
friends in silicon valley and across the
country because they provide the same
high end financial advice that the best
private wealth managers
delivered to the ultra wealthy.
But for any account size and at a
fraction of the cost. For instance,
they monitor your portfolio every day
across more than a dozen asset classes to
look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses.
Now would you do the same? Are
you doing the same? Probably not.
And the powers and the software wealth
front now manages more than $4 billion in
assets,
which is up from around 2.5 billion.
When they started
advertising on this podcast,
they're growing incredibly quickly. Unlike
old fashioned private wealth managers,
wealth front is powered
by innovative technology,
making it the most tax efficient,
low cost, hassle free way to invest.
They don't have bloated sales
teams or retail locations,
so they can deliver all of this
sophisticated financial advice and these
services at a fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor.
So at the very least,
go to wealthfront.com forward slash Tim
and take it they're free risk assessment
survey. It only takes a couple
of minutes and Wealthfront.
We'll recommend a personalized portfolio
of investments. In other words,
they'll tell you exactly where
they would put your money.
So even if you don't use their service,
you have a huge up and you have additional
information for making good decisions.
They use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make,
but should so go to wealthfront.com
forward slash Tim to get your first 15 k
managed for free or just to
get more details, check it out.
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class
performers of all different types,
whether they're from the worlds of
business, sports, entertainment,
military or otherwise.
And this episode we have Ricardo Semler
who was by popular request and it
certainly had a large impact on me.
He came up not too long ago in the very,
very popular podcast episode with
Dhh David Hannah Maia Hansen,
who is of the 37 signals base
camp and ruby on rails fame,
who also credits Ricardo with having a
huge impact on him. So who is Ricardo?
Cool. I always want to call Ricardo
because he is originally from Brazil.
He is the former CEO of Semco,
a Brazilian company,
best known perhaps for its radical form
of industrial democracy and corporate
reengineering.
And all of that will make more sense
as we get into the conversation.
We really focus on entrepreneurship
even though there's so much more to talk
about, including education and what
he's done with his Lumiar schools.
But going back to Semco under his
ownership or during his leadership.
Certainly both revenue grew
from $4 million us in 1982
to 212 million US dollars
or so in 2013 and his innovative business
management policies which are very
controversial, attracted very
widespread interest all over the world.
He's taught at Mit,
he's an many,
many other things and most recently he
has started a podcast which is checkout
called lead wise and you can find
that at podcast dot lead wise.
Dot Ceo on Twitter.
You can find them at Ricardo Semler or
at let's lead wise if you want to be pot
podcast specific so you can
check out both of those.
Facebook let's lead
wise and then Linkedin,
Ricardo Semler and I should also provide
some context for two very similar
sounding book titles.
So he wrote the seven day weekend in
2003 which had a big impact on me.
The four hour work week.
I'm not sure how happy he is about how
seemingly related those titles are.
But came about for those people who don't
know the story from the original title
of the book,
which was drug dealing for fun and profit,
which was the tongue and cheek name of
the guest lecture I gave at Princeton and
high tech entrepreneurship. Uh,
ultimately for at least 10 years,
I think it was around 2003 to 2013 or so.
And when the book was sold to crown
within random house at the time,
there were a few retailers,
I want to say it might've been Walmart
who really didn't like drug dealing for
fun and profit. So I, so I, I
quickly sketched out as did they,
I'd say a dozen or so titles and one
of the ideas was the two hour workweek
because that's how long it took me
to manage my company at the time.
But that seemed to unrealistic.
So I was like, all right,
we'll go up to four hours a week.
And then I tested that along with the
other titles in Google ad words and for
let's just call it $200 a week later
since Google mixes and matches the,
the ad headlines,
which were the titles and the ad text,
which were my subtitles,
I knew which combination at
the highest click through rate.
And that is how we ended up at the
four hour workweek. But no matter,
I will put a shots of a photograph of my
self made index at the beginning of the
seven day weekend, which is a great
book and I recommend people check out.
And uh,
this conversation ranges vary very widely
and I hope you enjoy it as much as I
did. So without further ado, please enjoy
my conversation with Ricardo Semler.
Carla, welcome to the
show. Thank you. Thank you.
I'm so happy to have you on the phone
and on the show because I have been a fan
for so long and I in fact have
this copy of one of your books,
the 70 weekend which has traveled
with me for at least 10 years now.
I bought it when it first came out and
I was looking at the index that I made
for myself in the very beginning,
which I'll have to take a photograph
of and send to you as a, first of all,
as it came up in my conversation with,
with Dhh on the podcast.
I just wanted to thank you
for sharing your experiences.
Obviously I have a copy of your
work week or a similar name and I'll have
to photograph or that to believe that
you've actually carried it around,
but it's great to, to to catch up.
I know you've been very sought full about
all these really deep issues of how to
live, how to work and uh, how
do you put wisdom into things,
which was my concern as well.
I think we'll,
we'll want to jump into that and also
talk quite a lot about education.
A lot of my audience has many, many quiz
questions about learning and education,
so we will,
we will certainly get to that.
But for those people who don't have a
lot of background and a lot of context,
could you give us perhaps just a
snapshot of where you grew up and your
childhood just as,
as a starting point and then we can depart
from there to many different places.
But that would be very
helpful place to start.
Sure.
And you know,
I was thinking about it the other day
when I've been trying to work with some
guys in the UN and elsewhere about
putting education platforms into refugee
camps in it. And it, it kind of
explains my background as well. My,
my parents were both, um,
Ostrin refugees and um,
my, my mother was a refugee in,
in all respects of the world.
And it says the sheep runaway from
Vienna to Shanghai.
I
spent 11 years in Shanghai,
but then was kicked out of Shanghai by
Maltitol in 1949 and then actually spent
18 months in a tent in a refugee
camp in the south of France.
And she was one of these displaced
persons who had no passport whatsoever.
And so it's,
it's very interesting how we see
different variations of the word refugee.
But the fact is that she then
became an an immigrant in Brazil,
which is the only place that accepted her.
And um,
and so much later I was
born and she had a, uh,
she lost seven pregnancies,
hand still borns, et cetera.
And so she always regarded
me as somewhat of a miracle.
And a Freud always says that
if your mother believes in you,
absolutely that you can do anything,
then you can do anything.
And that's the only thing it takes.
And so it was very interesting because I
grew up in a household that was already
a well to do and we had everything.
And um,
and when I got to about 12, 13, I got
involved with rock bands and then I,
I spend a lot of time as a Rodeo.
And then as the and playing,
I was never terribly good but enough to,
to kid all in and enough to trickle it
to all my friends into thinking I was
very good and going on
stage here and there,
which is I think probably
the most important part of
it, you know. And uh, so,
um, so why the by the time
I was 17 or 18, I was,
I was very much in that mode,
but my father then who was 50
years older than me and uh,
I always,
it was very interesting also because I
kept looking at us 15 years older men
span is almost my grandfather.
And um,
and I said I could never do
that myself and so forth.
And so promptly I had a son
not when I was 50, so, um,
he's now seven. So some of this stuff
comes back to bite you in the ass.
But the fact is that then I was
17, he wanted me to, you know,
he kept taking me to the
plant and staining Sunday,
all this will be yours because
of the manufacturing plant,
which makes pumps and very
heavy equipment. And he was
very engineering oriented.
There were about a hundred
people there and this wasn't,
had been there for a long time
and doing relatively well.
But then it started deteriorating.
So the, by the time I was 19 or 20,
the whole business, um,
double industry for that was,
it was in very bad shape at that point.
I had decided to do law school
because I didn't want to do,
I thought business school in general was
very restricted and very much turned to
the past and so forth.
And I'm wondering more and more
humanistic background that did that.
And then that joined the company in.
And when I joined the company,
I'm kind of following his swishes
while I was still doing law school.
Um,
I realized that we had a big,
the big difference in the way we saw
the world or how we would run things,
that it was very traditional and
he was wearing a three piece suit.
I was wearing a three piece
suit with a watch in my pocket. It
was pretty unbelievable. And then, um,
why was your watching your pocket?
Because this was my grandfather's
watch and my father were,
went in his pocket with a little gold
chain and pulled it out every so often,
you know, I was ready to
start smoking pipes, you know,
this is the world that was just staring
me in the face. It was very, very curious.
But,
and of course this was all colliding
with the rock guitarist and basis,
which I thought I was,
I had hair down to the middle
of my back until a year before,
you know. So this was all very strange
and it was a very strange world.
And I saw people getting, um, uh,
having to come to,
to the company and be searched on
their way out and have exact times.
And if there were five
minutes late and docking pay,
and this is an extraordinary world
compared to what I'd seen up to them,
let's say, in the world of rock. And, um,
so when I started looking at all that, at
a certain point, I told him, I said this,
we're incompatible here. This is
what I would do here is so different.
And probably you're saying
it would never work. So, um,
let me go do something else.
And um,
for a while he just kind of
took the bluff and said, sure,
go see what else you can do.
And I found out at that point that the
business world was more interesting than
I thought that I could
do something with it.
And I went out and started looking for
opportunities to do something on my own.
And that was not a world 35,
40 years.
It was not a world of startups
or anything in the sword.
So if you wanted to start a business,
this is all very hardware oriented.
So I went out and I talked to people
who were in the consulting business,
you know,
I want to buy a company,
but I don't actually have
any money to pay for it.
And if I were going to pay for it would
be my dad's by the end. Of course,
that makes no sense whatsoever.
And then I finally found a consultant
at pricewaterhouse of all places who,
um, helped me. He said, no,
you have to do the following.
We'll look for companies that are broke
and then have no money whatsoever.
They have a big debt.
And if you're not scared of taking on
that and you can buy these companies for a
dollar. And I said, the dollar
I have, let's go do that.
And so we looked at dozens and dozens
of companies finally got to one,
which was a ladder company, made
metal and wooden ladders. And um,
and I got to the point of signing,
there was 200 page contract that was
sitting at the lawyer's office to sign the
purchase of this company,
which was really a very high negative
worth of course because it hadn't been
dead how of problems. But the guy
wanted to get rid of it and I said,
give it to me.
And suddenly my father bursting
to the law office and he said,
what does it cost to pay the fine to do
this deal at the sort of longer sentence
than it was.
I remember it was $200,000,
which seemed like an enormous on
Monday and at the time. And so he,
he baited and we paid the fine and didn't
sign the agreement and then I started
with the company.
So those are very interesting beginning
this, this I think, and please
correct me if I'm wrong,
but sort of probably chronologically it's
close to something I wanted to ask you
about that a lot of my listeners
wanted to ask you about.
And that was when you
took the reins as CEO,
maybe you could describe
the circumstances, but the,
the firing of 60% of top managers as,
as one of the first decisions.
And,
and I don't know if that is as
straightforward as it might seem,
but the question that came up from a
lot of my listeners was how did you make
that decision?
And I would just love to
hear the circumstances
surrounding it and the thought
processes that went into
your first decisions, uh,
when that transition took place.
Yeah. And, and it's, it's
interesting. I mean, what,
what I told you a little while now
connects to that of course. But, and then,
and it's interesting the thought process
when you say, you know, your, your,
your listeners want to know this one or
that. And I just, I just started, uh, uh,
Lou, our guys have been
suspended a little podcast and,
and we've covered a leading wisely and
leading wisely is all about this issue of,
you know,
how do you make some decisions like that
one of firing most of the people and
how do you know that it's
folly or wisdom when you start,
you know? And so I'd gotten
to that point where, um,
it was either him or me in the sense
of there were two ways of trying to run
this. And at that point the
business wasn't doing very well,
which gave me an opportunity.
But as I looked out at these people,
maybe, you know, we had
a hundred odd people,
so maybe 20 of them a little bit more.
We're either managers or supervisor is
somebody wearing a leading capacity?
And I looked out at these people and
I'd already had a little bit experienced
with trying to change things and people
were always explained to me why it can't
be done. So they would listen
very patiently and then
they would say, yeah, okay,
but you're a new, you know, you're 19.
You've just that prior to this and the
fact as we've been in this business for
so long and there's this
and there's that event.
And I realized that in the amount of time
it would take me to turn these people
around and to deal with the,
um,
unconscious sabotage that
everyone who is in place, uh,
applies to everyone else.
You know,
anyone who was coming in to something is
always new and hasty and doesn't really
understand and you, and so it takes
a hair all the time in the business.
At that point, it was not doing well
enough to withstand the long cycle.
Uh,
and then I realized that the amount of
sabotage that I'd have in the amount of
interactions,
the permutations of firing three people
who then create an alert and panic and
the other six people who talked to the
other five behind our backs and so forth,
it seemed like we didn't
have the time for that.
And it seemed obvious that these
people were terribly, uh, in place,
uh, and, uh, completely calcified
with all these users had been there.
So I took a rash decision,
which may be only a 19 or 20 year
old would do, probably wouldn't have,
I don't think I'd ever occurs
to do that today again.
But I looked out there and I said,
we just sort of pull the bandaid off
this thing so that I can start the next
day. And so on one Friday
afternoon, I just called people in,
I had never hired anybody
much less fired anyway.
And then I fired out of the old 16,
17 managers and directors
and that included the CEO,
the CFO or anybody who mattered.
And,
and these people went home Friday
and didn't return on Monday.
And we spent the whole weekend going
through these people's filing cabinets.
This was all paper and going through the
filing cabinet and trying to figure out
what the hell is going on in this company.
And we would look at it and then we'd
see a customer and they would say, oh,
I wonder who this customer is that
we had no idea. And it was really,
it was really quite a
quite a rollercoaster ride.
But I think in the end it made us change
direction of course, very quickly.
So that 60 days in we were a completely
different company and then it was
possible to throw out the whole rule
book from, from nothing and say,
what does that, what, what part of this
do we really need? And what part of it,
which has just been here
forever and doing that slowly,
I think it would've killed me
and the other guys as well.
Did you have many conversations
before making that decision? Was it,
was it scary for you to do that? I
guess? Uh, it's just seems like such a,
uh, you said rash, but also, I
mean courageous in some respects,
decision for someone at that age,
in that position.
Did you have any conversations inside
your head or with other people that
allowed you to take that,
that leap and make that decision?
I'm just wondering what
sort of led up to it.
Yeah,
I'm imagining that there must have been
and I can think basically any one or
two people who from the beginning I felt
would be on the right side and they'll,
maybe I tested it with slightly,
but I already knew as well that I
couldn't tip off the system or the wrong
people.
And I didn't know enough people.
I remember talking to my dad a few days
before because he was about to go on a
trip to Europe and I said, uh, you know,
I have to do a few things here and it
might involve some of the, and he said,
and I imagined, I imagined,
uh, do everything while I'm in.
As soon as he,
I think he traveled and we traveled on
Thursday and I called everybody and on
Fridays. So, but I think it was,
it was knocking around inside my head
in the sense that, Geez, you know, if I,
if I tried to do this the old
fashioned way or the soul cycle, um,
this is going to be 10 times as hard,
but also the chance that I actually get
to the end of this as smaller and a,
I felt in many respects that
on top of it being rushed,
I felt I really had no option.
There was no time and we needed to do
this very quick. And now of course,
that gave me an opportunity to
have a startup, let's say, um,
on Monday from a,
a business that was already
30 years old on Friday.
You, uh, I want to flash forward a little
bit and I'm sure we'll fill in the,
some of the gaps in there will
be stories that will come back,
but could you please describe the,
uh,
I would love to know the actual meaning
of the title Vii Donda Appropriate Mesa
and which is,
as I understand it later became maverick,
but clearly in,
I don't speak Portuguese but seems
to mean something very different than
maverick.
Can you describe how that book came to be?
And as I understand it became the best
selling nonfiction book in the history of
Brazil, which is saying something. I mean,
there are a lot of books I've spent
some time in result to it that that's a
nontrivial accomplishment.
So what does [inaudible] mean?
Literally,
it means turning your own tables,
but it's basically
turning the tables with,
you're stuck in the middle there
to make it more self facing,
you know,
but it was really about an in Portuguese,
it makes a little bit more sense, but
it is in the same, in the same thing,
which is to say, uh, turning
everything upside down and so forth,
which was this whole process of starting
from scratch and changing the rules
entirety. And it was really just, Eh,
because let's say from maybe the five,
six years after this mass firing,
let's say in which we
started, uh, redoing things,
we started asking questions. And I don't
know, it seems a very simple process,
but actually when you do it,
you realize that potential,
which was a whole process of
asking three why's in a row.
That was the only thing we were doing.
And I said,
since we're starting this again,
tell me again,
why do we search people in the way I
knew all the people have to arrive at the
same time, et cetera. When
you ask three why's in a row,
the first why people have
a very good answer for,
they've been thinking about this for a
long time or they'd be living this for a
long time. Yeah. And so people say,
why do people have to be here at the same
time? And they'll look at you and say,
Oh poor kid look a little dense.
Let me explain to you, you know,
think I guy comes here and the guy next
to him on the assembly line is not here.
Yes I'm aligned. Does non
woo. That's the first,
the first set of whys and it
just becomes more sophisticated.
But they did the same thing
to me. It uh, law school,
the Harvard Business School,
everywhere I heard this same
condescending response to,
or let me explain it to you.
So the first why is the easy one?
And I always say that I have five
kids in the smallest one is seven.
And I always say that when you have
the three why's and you asked them,
they asked you something, anything,
they said that why is this this way?
And the first question is why is
easy to answer? And then they'll say,
but why that? And then you start getting
into a little bit of trouble, you know,
really, because by the third
way you have only one option,
which is to buy them an ice cream.
And
this is what happened to be there.
So I'd say,
why do we have to come in right
time at the same time? Or we say,
why were we all dressed the
same way wherever you are
wearing suits and ties. Oh,
you know, so that will look more
like your term. Okay, great.
Why don't we want to look
more like each other? No,
because this is the same with almost
anything you ask of business rules.
There was a reason sometimes somebody
who was concerned with something,
but it wasn't really essential
to what you're trying to do.
And so we would say if we can't answer
the three whys about anything or about
any rule, let's just throw
it out and see what's left.
And we were left with absolutely nothing,
hardly anything of, of really important.
And,
um,
and so we started organizing ourselves
around this new way of if you can't
justify it,
absolutely let's try to do it without,
and uh,
that went for organization
charts and boxes and titles.
And you know,
when we were asking things like,
why can't you just set your own title,
choose any title you want,
put it on him on a business card.
And if the guy who wants to,
who's going to buy from you and you put
their rather right VP regional sales
manager instead of trainee,
I don't care as long as he buys from
you and trust you and you deliver the
product. And off we go. And so we
started doing this for everything.
And so we threw out the organizations,
are we through our drop titles?
We said very quickly we
started asking questions.
Why doesn't everyone know
what everyone else makes here?
Why can't people set their own
salaries and nothing resisted.
Three wives in a row. And I met
the man I can. Long story short,
suddenly the company started doing well
and then instead of a hundred people,
we had 200 and then 500 and a thousand
and in 2000 and then at a point we said,
um, when people start to
say, oh, you know, you've got
to write a book, you know,
you've got to tell this story in a book.
And I said, no, I don't stop bugging us.
But at a certain point in time, I sat
down, I said, I think I'll write a book.
So I started on a Friday and I
ended up down the other Sunday.
So I spent nine days riding.
And uh, and that was it. And I,
it's interesting because I
considered that book so belonging to,
to, you know, the,
the sin air and not to myself that I
never corrected any grammatical mistakes.
And,
and it came to me from the publisher as
many times as you surely don't want to
correct that you,
this is silly what your role here.
And there's stuff that I'm
not at all proud of anymore.
Of course then there's a lot
of mistakes. And I said, no,
you can't touch it can
through them along to anybody.
And so what happened was I sent it out,
I finished it in ink and it
was 900 pages of pen and ink.
And I, I took it, I had,
I had someone type it and then I send
it out to the eight big publishers in
Brazil and the eight rejected it.
And uh, it didn't take them very long,
either eight rejected. And they said,
you know, nobody wants to hear anything
from Brazilian businessman. You know,
they're buying the coker and kill more
return and all these guys in their home,
nobody wants to hear
from resume businessmen.
And then one of the guys that talked to
me, he said, you know what we could do,
we could give this out as a
year end gift from the company.
Wouldn't that be nice? It's 300 calm.
Is there some? And I said, you know,
my ego is not small enough for
that. I can't do that. And then
I found a publisher who
was the night and I said,
this is not possible.
You've got to publish this.
This for me and a small
version and you can't,
you can't lose all that much money and
so forth. So finally the guy says, sure,
I'll do it. And we had a very
interesting discussion about, uh,
royalties because he said,
or what you get is 10% Reuters and
that's how that sounds good. And I said,
what if it sells more than 5,000 copies?
And so he laughed and said,
no. So, okay, 11% anyway,
we had this whole,
this whole table, because
I kept asking, I said,
what about 50,000 and then you need almost
fall off the table after uni as well
as make that 15% anyway,
so I got a 20%
of a million
sales and but what happened was I,
I really never thought,
of course that I knew what I was doing
and I knew this book was very necessary
part, but I just wanted at
least to get it out there.
But apparently it was a bit
like a surfboard, you know,
that you're sitting there and
suddenly the big wave comes the wave.
I didn't make,
you know,
there people were apparently ready to
think about a different way of doing
things. And so they took, they
took the book forward in it.
Nothing happened at all
because he put the book out,
there was no publicity,
there was nothing in about week later
somebody found it and then somebody wrote
a review and then it's spend 200 weeks
on the bestseller list of which 150 weeks
a number when it was very simple. It's
just when Mt Martha and apparently it hit,
it had um, uh, a moment, a nerve,
a time in which it went off on its own.
But so that's a long winded response to,
it's called turning the tables because
of this whole turning things upside down
and finding out that it works just as
well. And in our case a lot better.
A couple while I'll have a
million followup questions,
but I have a few that are
related to, we've talked
about so far. So the first is,
and this might seem super
specific,
but what is,
what is the right way
to fire someone or how,
how would you go about firing someone
now or to those entrepreneurs listening?
So of course you had your approach
when you first came into the company,
but how, how has that changed
or evolved over time? What is,
what is the right way to fire someone
if you need to let someone go?
You know, sometimes my, my
wife says that, you know, it's,
it's so nice being fired by you that I
keep thinking this was a very positive
thing and I see all these people
getting up here after you aside.
I really have to find this person.
Then they get up and they're smiling
and they're patting me on the back and I
said, what the hell are you doing with
his firing process? But the fact is this,
that um, one when, when you get close
to it, some people are surprised,
but most people have an inkling already
that things are not doing well. Um,
I have this, this, uh, if
someone's working close to me,
and that's the only situation of
course where there's firing situation,
but persons working
close to me and it's not,
it's not going places early on.
I do very little of that.
Let's do this again, let's do another
and another chance, another way,
another cycle, et cetera. So
it's highly, highly intuitive.
And so to me,
if it doesn't show right,
it's not good for the person
or for me to continue.
And so I'll sit the personality and say,
this isn't working.
And for many respects the personal,
so I didn't realize or I didn't think so,
not wait a second, what this and that,
but um, it's all about being very,
very exceedingly frank and saying,
you know,
and most of the time it's
a situation which I say,
you can definitely count on good
references. Let me see if I can help you.
Let's think about where you could
go from here instead of that.
And mostly I think that that's the bit
of white people in the end don't feel so
bad about it is because I look forward a
bit of a few months or a few years in a
city, you're going to be stuck here.
I want this from you. You're not,
you're obviously,
this isn't a fitting your profile
entirely and you're going to keep adding,
keep adding to that. But slowly
we're going to start the abrasion.
We'll sit in, you know, and I'll be
more ill humored about this or you'll
find that getting up on Monday morning and
coming to do this isn't
as fun as it used to be.
Well let's cut all this at the rule
and gives you a real chance of finding
something that, that makes you a lot
happier. And, and normally I'll say this,
this is in here. It makes me seem
like something you'd do well,
but let me tell you this, this doesn't
work but this, that you're good at,
you should be able to
find a way to do that.
And normally it ends relatively
well because it is so based on,
on transparency,
you know?
Definitely.
And when you subject these conventions
to the three whys and everything falls
apart or it just isn't justifiable.
So now you're effectively
dealing with a blank canvas.
How do you choose what to do first?
Or if somebody does this in a company,
is there particular order you might
suggest that they tackle things in if
they're just left with all of these
rules from all the way from say,
marketing to finance to hiring to fill
in the blank have have fallen by the
wayside because they can't be justified.
Where do you start?
Because I could see a lot of people
feeling scattered or becoming scattered.
How do you choose or how did you
choose what to do first, second, third.
You know when,
when you,
when you think Tim about what you
write about and what inspires you.
When are you going to
the issue of a Workweek,
a chef for a workout or
how to live a life wisely.
You're basically concentrated on process.
The process by which you do all of
this is the one that makes sense.
So I would definitely start by the
process that takes us out of bed.
You know, the bit that makes you get
up and go somewhere to do something,
that that process is the first one
that needs to be changed. So, um,
how often do you want to work?
How many hours do you want to work?
Who you want to work with in
what place you want to work?
That is the one that to me would be the
number one issue because if you have
people in your company,
organization,
wherever you are that are doing this
because you told them to or somebody told
them to her,
it's always been done that way.
Or people aren't stopping to think about
why the heck should I take the subway
and a bus and go to a place
downtown and so forth.
This is the stuff that is undermining
your whole opportunity to have the right
process.
So I would always start with do,
is this really what you want to
do? Oh yeah, I love doing okay,
but you love doing it at this time
of the day? No, not really. Actually.
If I could take my kids school person,
right.
This is the stuff that I would
take off, you know, what are the,
what's the stuff that you're
doing or how you're doing it,
which somebody asks for or
somebody thought was going
to be smart or was a good
idea four years ago.
This is the date,
I'm sorry to interrupt and this is
something you would ask of every employee.
Yeah. And, and we did of course.
And so we ended up of course,
was people who didn't want
to come at the same time,
who didn't want to work there anymore.
We went from one one building,
which was when we started
asking this question,
we had one central building and everybody
came to us and this was the obvious
solution. Um, within maybe
a year, year and a half,
we had 14 different places around Tom.
And so we would say go to the place
that's nearest your house or near as the
customer you want to visit
or to uncle anywhere. Uh,
but don't even tell us because we don't
want to have anyone who keeps tabs on
you because your process of how you want
to do this is the most important thing.
And let's negotiate you and us.
Let's contract for something
you're going to do.
Are you gonna sell 56
widgets a week? Oh, great.
So if you sell 56 widgets on Wednesday,
please go to the beach
on Thursday and Friday.
Do not show up and sell more widgets
because you're going to create an enormous
problem for engineering and manufacturing
and consumer has to go out and buy
another company.
And under those don't do this before
we thought it through your six 56 which
where you're going to do it from how
you did it is none of our concern.
Don't tell us, just tell the 56
witches now will always be fine.
And this is true for everything
else is true for accounting,
as for marketing and so forth.
And so the process of how you're going
to do this isn't necessarily yours and we
don't want to be in the way. So here
are 14 different places you can go to,
few wants, you can stay
in bed, we don't care.
Don't tell us how many hours you worked
or how hard it was still the widgets.
Cause we don't have any place to put
that information that that was the,
the whole focus on process.
And when you're asking why not a, B,
and c, right. And when you're, when
you're testing these assumptions,
are there any particular notable failures
that come to mind with tests that you
performed?
Oh yeah. And, and I, I can, I can think
of a few and I'll tell you she'll,
but the main thing is that the enormous
amount of mistakes that one makes in
organizations with your wife,
with your kids at the church in
a group battalion and so forth,
is so humongous that you have to
consider a bit, you know, the,
the Babe Ruth permutation that if you
just hit more home runs than you miss the
ball. But can you think, how
many times does it miss them all?
And here we have very little in general.
We have very little patience
for these mistakes. And,
and my thing is really to brush aside
the mistake and say, hey, that's great.
That was wrong. Let's try this again now
for a wrong again and again and again.
That's,
that's really no problem.
We just have to be batting
in the right direction.
So there's a lot of things that
we started that we thought was,
was really smart. You know,
we figured all this out. Um,
and for we, with the, with
the whole search thing,
that was a very big issue because we had,
um,
we had all these electronic components,
we had all kinds of stuff,
which people said,
just crazy.
People take this in their purses
and in their hair and so forth.
And we said,
it doesn't matter on the way out.
And I'm going back here 35
years, and it was open. This is,
this was a big issue because everyone
kept checking the stocks and there was
those always something
missing from inventory.
And this was all very expensive
stuff, which was easy to
take. We worked, you know,
in the motors were all copper
wires in and there was silver this.
And then there was, uh,
components and so forth. And, um,
and I was saying,
you know,
the process here is that I
cannot work with people that I,
I interact with and we try to do things
together with, I have empathy with,
and then I search on their way out to
find out whether they're stealing from me
that it's just not possible.
It can't be done.
And so for some time that
didn't work at all because, uh,
slowly are,
we had a lot of inventory problems and,
uh,
the amount of losses that we had in the
months following was obvious and people
would look at us, let's see here.
Silly. I, you know, it's getting worse.
And My, my reaction to that
at that point was, do we,
do we keep this inventory,
uh,
safe and the locked up and people
have to requisition. Yes, yes. Okay,
well let's give up that process as well.
And just leave the store
is completely open.
The inventory and anybody
can take anything.
And then for the first time we had to
decrease until the problem went away
because,
because the whole process was,
if we're showing you here in there that
we don't trust you and sign this and
lock this in and so forth, and then
we're just making sure you don't steal.
It's a crazy situation. It's always
a very small minority of people.
And as we put the process in place,
people started saying through
a form where they would,
it would come together at a meeting and
decide who they needed in their air for
the next six months and slowly the
system expelled the people who were just
stealing. And, uh,
I dunno what happened over
the years who've stayed in
these 35 years of people's
stolen more or less, etc. It, we
don't measure it. We have no idea.
We've never had any idea,
but it's never become an issue big
enough to worry about since, you know.
And so what I meant to say
was that we make a lot,
we made a lot of mistakes in
every one of these processes.
When we started telling people on the
assembly line, they take good time,
could come anytime they wanted.
They could leave their kids at school,
they could stay longer in bed.
Of course for a time the sandwich line
suffered and we didn't deliver some
products and people were
pulling their hairs out.
But then a few weeks later suddenly
these people realize. Then they'd say,
well wait a second, you're
not here. This is a seminar
I was going to move. So what time you
think you're getting here tomorrow?
And a whole new schedule
started coming into place.
So I'd say ultimately if the process
decision is to to trust people to believe
in people as people,
the issues go away with time and they
just look like mistakes in the short term.
I think this is actually a good place
to perhaps tie this to folks who are
listening who have say smaller companies.
So let's just say they have
fewer than 10 employees.
A lot of people listening
to this are entrepreneurs.
They might be Solo preneurs who were
doing their first hiring or people with
small groups,
small teams.
What are some experiments,
uh,
or questions or any type of assumption
busting that you might suggest they test
for themselves? Is the, are there any,
are there any good starting points for
people who have processes in place but
they're small teams, relatively flexible
but very, very resource constrained. Uh,
w well, where might they start
in terms of, of, of testing?
I think I'm doing your first
urge is to become organized.
Are, are a great place because,
um, when you have the two,
three and you're in your backyard or
and go Raj and suddenly something seems
viable and you're writing cold or
you're put together a small object which
suddenly has shop wants, um, you're,
you're in your most
primitive creative stage.
It's not dutiful and romantic and shine
dot coastal all around it or thorough.
It's really, um, your
first urge. When you,
when you start going places slowly and you
start realizing that people are
interested or there's more volume,
more expansion possible, that's when you
start looking around and say, whoops,
I need more people.
But very soon after,
and you might have eight or in your mind
have 12, and then suddenly you say, oops,
no, wait a and this, we're going to
go, we're going to become bigger.
I need to get organized.
I think this is probably
the single riskiest point
because it doesn't seem like
such a big assumption.
You might ask someone who supposedly
knows or you'll spend some time on the web
looking at literature of organization
and then suddenly you're stuck in a world
which starts a scribing in prescribing
and describing how you should be doing
things. Um, and I think that
that is the original sin,
let's say,
of organizations.
And so I would say resisting the rationale
that is being handed down to you,
that you would need to get organized and
I think is much more valuable than it
sounds. And people look at that
and said, well, wait a second.
I don't have the this and I
don't have a software that does that.
And if I don't give my payroll to that,
I'll never know when this will be wrong
and so forth. And you find that the,
the stuff,
let's say the bureaucracy that that has
to be dealt with is nothing like the
creative effort of communicating
and dealing with people
and giving them freedom.
And slowly you find that as you grow from
eight to 12 to 14 years, just they say,
oh, wait a second before we
could do this. But now I'm, I'm,
I'm not able to just hire somebody
or agree and contract for something.
I need to know what they're doing.
And I think that when you start asking,
why do you need to know all, because
if, I don't know, I can't, um,
following them on slack, but I don't
really understand what they're doing.
I don't know where they really come in.
I don't know if they're working harder
or less than someone else where they
should be making that. And
maybe the answer to all of
this is it doesn't matter.
You know, this or not. If
you get down to the very,
very few things that really
mattered to you being unorganized,
a parent, which is not knowing a lot of
this stuff becomes completely irrelevant.
I've had now in the last two years,
Tim,
I've been dealing with
kids, you know, 25 year old,
28 year old, 32 year
olds who have, uh, oh,
I've started businesses with, um, one,
one of the businesses, which
is a, in Holland for example,
these guys started this
business and I have some, uh,
minority partners and have some equity
partners, et Cetera, who I have never met.
I've never met personally.
I've never met on Skype.
I have a few people who went to, who was,
let's say, CEO of a startup, et cetera.
And I have not the slightest idea what
it looks like, trees tall or short.
I haven't very generic
idea of age and so forth.
And one of these people
the other day I was,
I set up time to talk to and they said,
oh, the time's not very good. And I said,
why not? Oh, because I live in
Australia. And I said, what? So, eh?
And I said, well, how the
hell did I know that said,
you're never asked where there.
And so this,
this whole process is now I think one
in which I would highly recommend to
people that they do not fall into the
trap of saying, I need to get organized.
I need to know all of this.
Because the essence of what people
are trying to do with their lives,
their businesses and the organizations,
they really don't require the amount
of information and communication and
structure that you think it needs.
You know,
w what would you suggest they
focus on in instead of that?
I'm just in maybe the way to frame it is
besides a flipbook focusing excessively
on the bureaucracy and
putting systems in place, um,
what are some of the other most
common mistakes that people in smaller
companies,
and I should say also that we might not,
those companies may stay the same size. So
they may, let's just say that, you know,
10 person company,
they're creating a great product,
but they want to scale in revenues,
potentially not headcount. Um,
so a,
either one of the most,
some other common mistakes that the
people in that position make or be,
what should they focus on instead
of what might they focus on instead?
I think there's a lot of
rationalization and a lot of
tricking yourself, you know, because,
and I think that's a very dangerous
enemy that you don't really
realize because whether
you're going to grow or not
and it's doing well,
et Cetera,
what happens is that there's a point
where you try some of the things that
you're,
you're testing out there and that you
tend to insist very much either on an
impulse on intuition or
an early result and uh,
and you say, this is, this
is going to work, this is,
that's where the difference between
perseverance and self trickery is,
is very fragile.
It's very delicate.
And so I would say that
testing impartially,
finding a way to test him partially
whether what you're doing is,
is really worth what you're doing and
the way you're doing it, et Cetera,
et Cetera,
I think is a very difficult
one that people sometimes
take a heck of a long time
to do and then sometimes the businesses
there, the money's there, et Cetera,
but essentially there,
there was nothing really of substance
there and it might take you years and
years of spinning your wheels to realize
it and sometimes when something does
not go through in the end you start
remembering those small comments or those
people who,
who were naysayers all along who you
were just pushing it out of the weight in
order to do what you had to do
because you knew it was right.
This whole process of really
poking at what you're doing,
the product or the entity or
the time you're taking is a,
is a disheartening process most of the
time because very few things really are,
are feasible and most of the
things will run for a while.
And I think that if you could poke at
that early on and be excessively, um,
transparent and humble about whether that
that exists really as an opportunity,
I think that would be the, by far
the most valuable thing you could do,
which you've,
which of your books would you
suggest say that's small organization
entrepreneurs start with and which books
besides your own have you gifted the
most to other people?
You know, the, the, the one that you
mentioned, the, the seven day weekend is,
it is a good place to,
as with many other books is it is a good
place to poke around also inside your
own head and to look for some insights.
You know, in the end, when I, when I,
when I wrote the book originally,
um, in and Brazil was,
was still a relatively closed at
elite environment for business people,
et Cetera. So obviously because
the book has sold a good quantity,
most people had read it and I was
kept giving autographs to taxi driver.
It was a very, very, a very small
microcosm was living in.
But I remember the second
occasion that has happened to me,
which was being stopped on the
street and somebody saying, you know,
I read your book and it changed my life.
And they would go off and quote
somebody else's book in time
when this happened the second
time I said, shit, this is,
this is not about me at
all. You know, this is, um,
so let me stop right here. Because,
and of course at that point,
there was all kinds of campaigns for me
to run for mayor and for president and
become Brazil's Trump,
you know, because this is,
people get lost along the way and they
start believing in their own bullshit,
you know?
And,
and the interesting thing here was about
going back to the issue of the book was
that, uh, it's when you, when
you come across an insight,
which was already yours, and you see
it in writing, that's when you say,
this book changed my life.
You know,
but really insights where you
go there and you said, Geez,
I never thought of that.
And there is some of that it has to add
to something that you believe in or that
jives with your moment and so forth.
So I think that I'm putting
too much weight and too
much importance on something
that you got out of summer.
I got an insight,
doesn't remind us that this intuition
and this since I was growing inside you
already, we're just waiting
for some clarification of it,
but that kind of answers the second bit,
which is I,
I taught for for several years at the
Sloan school at Mit and I had a group of
Mbas and as long as a very fun
group and I used to go there, um,
in the fall quarter and, um, and, and I,
I'd tell them,
look,
this is what you have to read to
understand business and organizations.
And so far it's time and I was of to
make this available on the
MIT side anyway and so forth.
And then the books that were
there were Marco polos travel,
one book, uh, uh, CAFCA parable,
um,
a,
a yoga book on synchronicity and so forth.
And so these,
these kinds of books and calf
guy think is extraordinary. Um,
these kind of books I think give you an
enormous insight into the people who are
doing things or why they're doing things.
Um,
rather than the whole set of
how to, you know, and when you,
when you run away from the how tos into
the issue of how you get to real wisdom.
You know,
we've been at this for a long time.
We've been in this agriculture and then
we were in the industrial area and then
we were in the information age
and we were in the knowledge age,
but we don't get any closer
to the age of wisdom.
And something is terribly
wrong for population.
And then the humanity has been around
for so long and doesn't get closer to
wisdom.
You know,
when you think about organizations and
you ask you to show me one democratic
organization or business
environment in the world,
or to find one wise company as a company,
et Cetera,
these are all almost impossible to find.
So answering your question,
I would say that the books
that stopped to think about,
why the heck do we do
the things that we do,
which are in calf car and Freud
or in younger and thorough.
I think that those will answer at business
world much closer than people think
when they say, okay, that's
all very good and well,
but that's all philosophy and that's
all airy fairy and touchy feely.
But I need to get down to answer this,
how come,
which people how until Friday.
But this process I think is much,
much stronger from a
philosophical point of what,
what makes you want to
get up in the morning, uh,
and how you let the other people
around you do what they want to do,
how they want to do it
and get out of their way.
And then that is a philosophical issue
that I think would solve a lot more
issues of people went from that filter
on, which, you know, definitely.
Do you have any particular
books or writing of Kafka that,
uh, that come to mind that
you would recommend? Yeah,
there's one that I used
always there, which was, uh,
which was wonderful.
It's a collection of parables.
There's only one and
there's a set of parents,
but one of them is especially interesting
is called before the law number four.
The law is only three pages long.
And I used to,
I used to sit on top of this teacher's
desk there in Cambridge and read this to
the, to the kids, you know, the NBA kits.
And this was really interesting because
I really felt like I was reading to my
small kids and I'd sit there and say,
let me read this to you.
But the fact is it's only two and
a half pages long, but it just,
it just tells a story of a guy
who sits in front of a door,
which is open and has this big guy who
is guarding the door and he's cost sack
and he's closed this big for
Colton is enormous and he's scary.
And the guy asks him, um, uh, whether
he can go in and he says, sure,
you can go into the doors open,
but don't forget to further on there's
another door with a guy who is scarier
than I. And then another door and support.
And then the guy says, well, wait,
I think I was just waiting
a bit here. And, uh,
this goes on and on until this guy's
getting older and older and older.
And then finally when he's about to die,
he's lying there on the floor.
And then the guy,
the guard bends down and he says,
um, uh, and he asks the guard and he said,
now that I'm about to die and I have no
more forces to go through anyway, uh,
what is beyond that door? What's going
to happen to the guard? Says, well,
this store, it was only for you
and since you are now going to die,
I'm going to close it.
Okay. And it's a wonderful,
a wonderful exercise
in realizing that each,
for these doors that you did not go
through, we're only for you. Okay.
And everything that we're comparing
ourselves to all the time and the size of
our businesses and the health of the,
the wealth of that and how good our
family is and how good our life is.
Whereas happiness,
whereas wisdom, et Cetera,
it all really answers this one issue that
this store is there only for you when,
if you don't cross it, uh, it'll
close when you die, you know?
No, I, uh, I've been struck with how much
I was a nonfiction purist for a really,
really long time and was fortunate
to have a few people intervene.
And the amount that I've taken
from books like Dune or Zorba,
the Greek and since they're
told in a narrative form,
have actually stuck compared to say,
the dryer in some cases.
Nonfiction has just been extremely
eye opening and liberating for me.
I want to ask about,
or this is really a question from a fan.
So a Philippe Moist,
I don't know how to pronounce his name,
but this is,
this is a part of his question. Uh, so he
needs, is referring to you. He wants it.
He made a big fire in his backyard and
burned every article, book, interview,
everything he had done as a symbol to
not look back. Has this been done again?
And how is his relationship to the past?
So it, could you elaborate on this?
I don't know if it's accurate or not,
but uh, if, if you could comment on that,
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
Yeah. That was when I
turned 50, so I'm 57 now.
So when I turned 50, um, I
looked at my, why Britain,
I looked around me and so
forth and I said, shit,
there's a lot of stuff on me here.
You know,
I have my books and all these languages,
38 languages. I have a thousand articles,
I have DVDs, I have cds, I have even,
you know, of course the video, cause
I don't even know I would play that.
But I had it and I said,
there's something wrong with
this stuff, you know, one, um,
I don't need it anymore for my ego.
I think I'm all set or I need to figure
it out what my therapist but not here.
And two, I have these five kids, you know,
we're going to run around a and suddenly
they're going to find that I'm larger
than life and people are going to say,
well, are you going to follow your own?
Are you going to run your dad's
company or going to? And I said,
that's a terrible imposition to
make on them, you know? And so,
um, I thought there were
two things holding me back.
One of them was that if I remember that
I did this and I did that and I have
this and I have that award
and I have to have that, um,
I have a very wrong sense of very
superficial sense of, of who I am.
So I thought that if I get rid
of all this stuff, I'm also, um,
a a lighter for the,
the,
the trip that's in front of me and that
I can look good things from scratch and
say, let's forget all that. What,
what would I do now and how do I kind
of zero based my life from Huron?
And two,
I didn't want these kids to be burdened
by the idea that your dad this year,
that that. So, um,
what we did was we just started a bonfire
in the backyard and it took us about
five or six hours to burn everything.
We were just burned 100%.
And so just like your SD,
this is in Sao Paulo or where were you?
I live up in the mall. Just wondering
what your neighbors thought. Okay. Yeah,
they didn't call the, the, the fireman.
So we just spent hours,
Bernie on this time and it takes a hell
of a lot longer than I thought it did.
And, and VHS tapes don't burn very
well and a lot of black smoke.
So we get hours of this.
And so it's now been seven years since
there is no shred of anything of mine in
the house anywhere in that respect.
And the good part about it is,
is my five kids, they really don't
have the slightest idea what I do. And,
uh, and if you ask them,
someone might say, I'm a writer,
or some might say I don't do very much.
And I'm like,
I've never taken them to a company.
I've never told them that one
day this could be yours. And, um,
so they,
it never entered their mind that they
know that we have money because they
couldn't look around. But they've also
learned from the very beginning that they,
they've gone to public school with
kids who have nothing whatsoever at all
along. They go to the house
of these kids were very, um,
humble and they've just learned
to accept that there's luck.
There is luck when you bought
it. You're, you're, you're,
you're born in a family that has money.
There's other things that are talent
and the kid plays soccer 10 times better
than you. And if they've found
that there are other variations,
but the one of, uh, your
father's this or that,
that one they'd,
they've never caught up on.
And so that was the whole rationale back
there. And I'm very happy that I did it.
Now I don't need to, every seven
years do anything because of course,
nothing else comes in.
Anything I get, uh, we,
we throw out as it comes in,
anything that has my name or is it
about me or is from you, etc. We just,
we don't keep it.
And that way it keeps relatively clean.
I want to come back to the parable and
the door and the door's being yours and
yours alone.
This trap that
some people fall into in
terms of comparison and
keeping up with the Joneses.
And just as context for people,
I live in silicon valley,
for those who don't know and irregularly
interact with people who might have net
worths of hundreds of millions of dollars
who are miserable because the other
person with hundreds of millions or maybe
billions has a larger jet than they do
or something like that.
And I'm looking at various
right yachts or fill in
the blank pissing contest.
And I'm looking at the notes that I made.
I must have been in 2003 in the
seven day weekend. So we have,
I'll just give you a couple of samples.
One 68 find talent than opportunity,
not job description.
Then talent 71 the reason for work,
one oh four Max personal
wealth is 12 million.
That's what I'm going to dig into in
a second one 23 no more than six month
business plan or or a six month
plans versus long term plans.
And I have dozens of these,
but what I wanted to do is
turn to 104 because that uh,
I,
I'd love to read a small piece of and
then just to hear you perhaps elaborate on
it and perhaps your thoughts
have changed somewhat, uh, to,
to hear is just find out
whether I actually wrote it
myself or not yet. Exactly,
exactly. So this is the
paperback. This is on one oh four.
I have a theory about wealth.
My friends just sigh when they hear this.
My theory is that the maximum
personal wealth is $12 million.
And I've done some calculations with
economists to bear out this capitalistic
and admittedly provocative number, not
a cent over 12 million. After that,
all millionaires are the same.
And then I'm going to jump down
and I'm skipping a few paragraphs,
but you call this the Davinci constraint.
And then the example is a neighbor,
a neighbor of mine in Sao Paulo,
built a house that reminds me of a
South American dictators compound.
He may have spent his entire
allotment of 12 billion on this house,
but now his problem is Leonardo who
points out that human cannot possibly feel
at ease in such a disproportionate house.
Certainly my neighbor can live,
they're open at two photographers from
design magazines and be admired from afar.
But in winter he'll huddle in the
tiny TV room on the second floor,
withdrawing from the cavernous rooms to
seek a more human scale. And then Jay,
I'm going to bump down another
two paragraphs. And uh, I really,
I like this lion a lot, which is
collecting money as like a massing.
Any other item, by definition, no
collector can ever be happy. So I was,
I'd love to just hear your
thoughts on this and uh, if, if,
if they've changed it all because this
is something that a or it's a temptation.
This is comparison and growth
for the sake of growth. More,
I need more and more and more. That leads
a lot of people to be very miserable.
Uh, could you, could you
just elaborate on, uh,
on this thinking?
I think nowadays when you,
and this is what this is about,
15 years old or something.
Yeah, a little bit less. Um,
I think in these,
in last decade
and a half left,
I think that the number of people who
have come to realize or to accept the
intellectual concept that money doesn't
buy happiness and a growing for growth's
sake and comparing yourself to everyone
else ends badly. And I think about it,
people have accepted this as a thought
and then something in the back of their
mind says, yeah, but you know,
if I had a 12 or 20 or $50 million,
everything would be a lot easier.
And it's only these guys
who really have the money,
who keep bullshitting about how money
is not important. This is the right,
this is where, this is how it, how
it comes down with after so much,
so much time thinking about this.
Basically we're in a world post 1989,
let's say when the Berlin Wall came
down, we're in a world that says, oh,
capitalism has won.
So there was no such thing anymore as
soviets and communists and so forth. This,
this stuff we've now proved in the world,
has proven that money is the
real kingdom of the world,
is a monarchy and the
king is money. And, uh,
of course guys who do this
better than other people, uh,
have now taken this to new proportions,
which is natural.
It's just doing more and more and
more and more of the same. So if I,
if my house were big enough
to huddle to 300 people,
and these were some of the people
from around your house, let's say,
and some of the, most of, some of
the wealthiest people in the world.
And I were to invite them over for
dinner and they were to accept,
I would have it, my dinner. Uh,
the wealth equivalent to half
of the population of the world.
So I couldn't have in that that dinner,
people who have more money than three or
three and a half billion people around
the world now that is money
is king rationale taken to
its most logical extent.
And uh,
and I started asking myself and a task
on a Ted talk and it was the line that
that got the most reaction
from people over time,
which was if you're giving back,
it's because you've taken too much.
And, and, and people are, you
know, I have to give back to that.
When you think about this and you say, you
know, one of your is not your neighbor,
he's in Seattle, but let's say the Bill
Gates. So, or, or her Warren Buffet,
Warren Buffet says, boy, you know, I've
been so good at this stuff. You know,
that I've now made according to
his calculation a few years ago,
I now made $30 billion more than I need.
Oh, okay. So what am I going to do this,
let me give it to people who really need
it and so forth with he gave it to Bill
Gates, right? Right. This was the,
this was the full Russia
now and so there's something
wrong with people who have
a lot of excess money of course,
because you're saying let's find someone
who's already trampling around Africa
and meeting tribes and trying to
give money to aids and so forth.
But the fact is that once you start,
you're caught in this collection mode,
which is you'll always find a reason
for thinking. You need more of that,
but it is taking away from something.
It's taking away from your kids or it's
taking away from sitting in the backyard
and reading another book or
it's taking from somewhere.
There's no such thing as a,
I will work harder for a time and then
I will have the money and then we'll,
and then everything will be all right
because that moment never arrives.
And I think people realize that evermore.
They just,
people in general of course feel that
there is a level of comfort that in your
mind about your worries about the future
and the money's in the mortgages and so
forth that will, boy, if you could
have that least that it, you'd be okay.
This 12 million almost parable
rationale was to say, look,
let's put at least an upper limit on this
at a point where the have a house here
in apartment there and
something on the beach,
on some of the animal and then having an
and do anything you want and go to long
vacations in Paris. That was at that time
that you'd have to bring it up to date,
but it was Tom and the
doctors did everything.
There was nothing you could
not do it Tillman from then on,
this was an issue of a
ego vanity or obsession.
It was something else too and it no
longer had anything to do with money.
On the lower end.
You see all these guys who are doing
work on finding a happiness levels and
serotonin levels and what it
takes to be minimally happy.
But people are always looking in India
at the people who are untouchable and so
forth and finding, uh, levels
of happiness that are high.
And so I think people kind of
accept the idea intellectually,
but that I think the feeling
inside is always okay,
but I had only 200 grand more or finally
this then everything would be okay.
I think that that isn't going away,
Tim,
in the sense that I don't think humanity
is getting wiser and slowly we'll
realize,
but intellectually was the first step,
which I think humanity took and now
starts to accept every time more that
there's something dramatically
wrong with zero 1%.
It's not even the 1% but zero
1% having such tremendous,
well end this whole amassing wealth
because the wealth is going to the smarter
guys and the smarter guys are the smarter
guys who are able to siphon money, uh,
away from everything else into
their own pockets. I'm on.
It's a very dismal situation.
And you come to think about it today.
You think about reading and thinking
about the past a little bit, Tim,
you think about the robber barons like
Rockefeller and Carnegie and Vanderbilt.
These guys were all a monopoly players.
You know,
these are the guys who were setting up
trusts and almost everything that they
did at the time would be illegal
today. Now, these barren Roy,
these robber barons are people that we
somehow or other are very impressed with.
You know, we'd love to be today, uh,
called to dinner,
buy by one of these rubber barons.
But is there a dramatic difference today,
Tim,
when you think about it in the biggest
corporations in the world and these
people,
many of the people who started
writing code and doing
wonderful things and so forth,
which are now all about
monopolies and trusts. And, uh,
suddenly the guy like Trump says,
come to Washington and play with me
and everybody says, where's my play?
And I'm ready to play.
There's something wrong with this whole
process because money keeps calling
money. And it makes very, uh,
very disappointing people out of the
ones who've been seeking money as a big
issue, money, power and so forth.
And you've seen it in all the films you've
read it and all the books you've seen
it with people, you know,
it doesn't end well,
but it doesn't stop any of these people
giving up other things in favor of that
which in a money world and
[inaudible] king oriented money world,
uh,
people seek.
And that's the bit that I think
most people have found to be silly,
but there's still chasing somehow.
And that's was the whole
bit about the tournament.
And how do you use the question,
what for
when you, when you do the three
why's in a row and so forth,
you end up with a
process questions and um,
and they're, they're very good for, um,
removing obstacles and things that,
that are silly that you do or that
you're involved in doing. But, um,
it still doesn't answer the,
the question that has to do with wisdom
and that one is what the hell far am I
doing this?
And that's a very,
very tough one because
you could eventually even
answered the three whys of for
a process or for way of doing things.
And you can fix that by asking the
three why's in a row. But when you,
when you answer,
try to answer in your marriage with your
kids in the place where you would work
at the chorus,
you go toward the church that you attend,
when you start trying to answer what
I'm doing this for, then I think you're,
you're getting to the,
to the religious and things,
but you're also getting into
real trouble because that,
those are the really difficult ones
to ask. There's, there's really,
all of us have only one question
in the world in our lifetime,
and one kid of mine asked
me that when he was three,
the other one is four and one.
We're sitting in a Jacuzzi when he's
three and he said that, why do we exist?
There's nothing else to
ask and there's nothing,
there's no other question to
ask for the rest of your life.
It will never answer it.
And so forth.
And this issue of what
for am I doing this?
Why am I waking up in the morning?
I go through this and why am I doing,
what am I doing a podcast for?
What good is this going to do? And
going further because you'll say, oh,
because you know,
I want to help people and I want all
these people to make their lives better as
you know. Okay. But what for? Oh, you
know, so that the humanity will be better.
What for? Oh, what for?
Because essentially I cannot live with
the idea that I'm not making the world
slightly better than it
was, uh, when I was born,
even though, uh, chances are, and,
and statistics tells you this
is not the case at all, but I,
but for me to feel that way, I need to go
do this. So I needed to do the podcast.
I need to write a book,
I need to speak at need to do all this.
But it's not because I hope that
people are now driving the car.
They'll suddenly stop and get out and
skip and jump to the house and say,
I've found new ways to do everything in
my life and everything we'd better from
wrong. But it's about my feeling
that I'm, I'm being useless.
And so this whole,
what four issue is,
is used for that as a key
to try and answer really why
you do the things you do,
what people listening.
You're very well spoken guy.
So they might look at your track record,
look at the accolades,
listen to you speak and imagine that,
uh,
you always been confident,
always known what to do.
Could you share any particular dark,
difficult times or time that comes to
mind and how you found your way out of
that?
And on several occasions I've been,
let's say, close to the brink of,
of things, um, not working to a
point of undoing everything. So, uh,
a few years after I started was
the first time I, I ran into,
you know, we rented it to
such a financial difficulties.
I remembers specifically driving
to the plant and thinking what it,
what it would take and what it would
mean that people have to talk to, to, um,
to,
to take the company into receivership
lists or the company was going broke and
what would I do as, and
that was to me, the, the,
the closest I ever got to the end, let's
say, because I was the only, I don't know,
21, 22 and suddenly everything I tried to
do was completely wrong or was working.
And, uh, we came close to
the brink at that point.
And so what I found, I
think in, in that, and some,
some moments later,
I've never,
we had never come to that same
financials to Trish and, uh,
anymore.
Exactly.
But I'd come to that situation looking
at a marriage is looking at how I was
raising kids,
looking at the opportunity to have a
much richer life and finding myself stuck
in the old traps that I'd set for myself
of doing things that I still had to do
because I said I was going to do them
and trying to, and so this whole process,
I think there were many dark moments
in which a four in front of let's say,
family or business or
a wife or, or, or, um,
choices for roads were, uh, looking back,
I realized either that,
uh,
it wasn't as dark as I thought it was
and I was just scaring myself into things
or to that I was,
luckily I got through that,
that bend in the road, et Cetera. So the
answer answers, first of all, no, there's,
it's far from easy,
even though I've been terribly
lucky all along. And so, uh, if,
if you say,
let me tell me the story of the 10
companies that you started that went bust.
That's easy because there's
more than 10, uh, the,
the amount of people that you've put
together to do something that became
nothing.
The kind of hopes you had four things
that you are going to do that went
nowhere. You know? And, and
I've written plays, I've,
I've put on plays and then
spent a year in the theater.
We're learning all about drama and
putting place together and so forth.
And I've been lucky enough that most
of this stuff kind of wanders off or is
reasonably acceptable so that I
can move on. And I think that the,
the real fears are always when you, you
know, somebody calls you and says, Oh,
you're the, for example, this two or
three weeks ago somebody called me and I,
my older kid was snowboarding and he says,
I'm calling you from the hospital.
We have to operate on your son.
You know,
things like that where your whole life
just kind of falls apart beneath you.
You go and do it needs to be done,
but you realize how fragile it is to
think that you're successful and you have
these big houses and you have all these
people working for you and so forth.
But this stuff is all very,
very delicate and very fragile.
So I think there was a lot of dark
moments in which you realize what,
what little it takes for you to kind of
lose everything that you were standing
on.
You know?
Are there any,
let's say,
philosophies or principals that you
rely on to handle those situations when
you're reminded of how fragile things
are or uncertainty strikes or fortune
blows in a direction that throws
things seemingly off, off balance?
Yeah. I have, I have a kind of a
nurturing and unwavering
belief that we're very,
very insignificant and had really no
idea what's going on and we're not,
we're not given,
it's not given to us to
understand anything that's
really important. You know,
any,
anything that you say is really,
really fundamental in life. We know
nothing about, we know nothing about love.
We know nothing about, we know know
the all the really important things.
We don't know.
He should take an hour.
You'd go to a doctor and
you go for a second opinion.
That sort of being et cetera.
You will always realize that.
The first question though, first, why man,
do I have this where you have this
because you're a nerve on this, the debt,
the second when et Cetera, but the third
y to any doctor is that we don't know,
right? Everything is that we don't
know anything that is really important.
We don't know. Um, and so my feeling
is that because of this, this,
uh, insignificance,
which is the, let's say,
paired with the fact that we're terribly
important to ourselves and we're almost
a hundred percent of our
importance to ourselves. Uh,
we're also insignificant any other regard.
And we noticed that when,
when somebody passes away or
when we remember something to,
we'd forgotten entirely that this
stuff is all becomes dust very quickly.
And so my feeling when, when things
are darker going badly or is that,
um,
it doesn't seem reasonable to me.
It never seemed reasonable to me
to for things to go completely are.
And so I,
my feeling is that,
I'm sorry to go completely one Ari.
I mean going completely wrong,
are going completely south and you know,
and my feeling there Tim, is
that, you know, if you're,
if you're really not
spending most of your time,
I'm tricking people into
things and finding uh,
ways on the side to make things work
or to make money and you're not, um,
you're doing your, your basic,
uh, humanity is basic in place.
My feeling is that you'll be alright,
you'll be alright.
And I think that's what carries
me through in the end. Now,
it's not religious,
it's not structured in any form,
but it's this kind of feeling that you
don't have to do all that much just to
Plod along without, um, without being,
um,
I'd say it's not even a naive,
you know,
so the whole rationale of
every time we have these small,
the choices,
the whole day long and by week and
month and years as we don't buy,
it's very easy to differentiate between
that which is a little bit less self
serving and that which is, um,
which is only for your own good.
And if you make enough
of these choices along,
I think that at these dark moments
where it is moments of enormous risk,
it's kind of like a destiny or an,
uh,
a balanced that is in place and that
takes care of you somehow. You know?
So on a semi related notes,
is there any particular,
uh,
challenge or goal that
you're facing right now?
You could choose any
personal or professional
that you could describe and how you're,
how you're tackling it,
how you're going about it.
The other day I told my wife,
I think I said this at a
talk or something that I'm,
that I'm facing an empty
bucket list, you know, and,
and my empty bucket list is all about
saying this, that, um, you know,
my family has all,
everyone in my trauma had melanoma.
I had a former, very drastic cancer,
which is very quick. And,
um, and I don't know, 15,
20 years ago I was already a scanned and
they told me it's a time where we did
that on a hundred percent
chance of melanoma and cancer.
And I've actually had it two, three times
and then in the meantime, but if you,
if you watch out for it,
of course you can be quick and remove it.
And I just had surgery again about three,
four months ago,
found a new one and it, there's nothing
to it really. You, you identify,
you know what it looks like. You go
there, you have it removed and off you go.
But I kept thinking, uh, you know,
sitting in front of my, my oncologist,
my cancer doctor looking at me and
saying, well, Ricardo, this time it went,
you didn't see it.
It was on there in your back and you
have three months left or six months. And
it happened to my parents and
two people to others before them.
And I kept thinking she's,
I don't want to be in that situation
where suddenly now I have to go to ball
games with the kids and now
I have to travel to places.
I haven't been enough to write that play,
which I know we're rolling.
So that's crazy.
So this is just something else.
And that's when I started
what my wife doesn't like,
the name I give,
but on Mondays and Thursdays I have what
I call terminal days and terminal days
are the two days a week in which, um, um,
my schedule is always completely clear.
I have nothing.
And I do on those days what I would've
done had I heard this conversation from
my oncologist. And so I've been
doing this for quite awhile.
And so my weekends are with the
kids and family and so forth.
And Mondays and Thursdays I only do what
it is I would do if I had just recently
learned that I had a terminal
disease and sounds dark.
But it isn't really because it's just
all about the freedom that you've just
gained and these days that
you've just gotten back, um,
to do whatever you want to do,
the way you do it,
and trying to answer to yourself
what you really want to do.
Because in the beginning you,
you have these long lists of things
you would do if you had the free time,
but it's not,
not really true.
So I'd read all these books which
are sitting there and I hadn't read,
I listened to all this music,
which I hadn't,
but you do this for an hour or two or
three, but then it gets old as well.
And there's a reason why you
didn't do enough of it before,
but it sounds like you'll be able to do
this for hours on end, but you won't.
And so if you're healthy and
you're in good shape and so forth,
and you have your entire day
ahead of you and nothing to do,
you start answering very,
very interesting questions about what,
what you really want
and what really moves.
So it's still going back to answer
your question, the fact is that I've,
uh,
I'm not left with goals and I'm left
with a whole set of wonderful processes
that I love and I'd love
to do again and again,
but I no longer need or want to
do something that I can measure.
The metrics I think have
gone away. Um, this,
this process of doing what I want
with the people I love that I'm on,
that's entirely a process on its own.
It's a goal on its own. And so there,
there's no longer, I have no wishes for
things that I could buy with money. Uh,
you know,
my kids and my wife are constantly
frustrated by the fact that
there's nothing that they
can buy me. Um, you know,
because it's, it's gotten to
that point where, Eh, I don't,
I don't need it or don't
want it or it doesn't,
doesn't tickle my fancy and so forth.
So I'm not left with metrics saying I'd
love to have another this or the money.
I've,
I've been doing math now I think Tim,
on my personal finances for
30 something years or more,
40 years on the same rationale,
which is how much do I need to have
enabled to lead the life that I do?
And Swiss bankers used to say that you
need to have 20 times more than you spend
per year. And it kind of, as
a rule of thumb, that's not
bad, you know, because that,
that says you need about a 5%
return on my knees. You have.
So if your lifestyle costs too,
and you say,
it takes me $5,000 a month to live
minimally the way I want that 60,000.
And so you need the assets in the
value of a million to house plus money,
whatever.
So,
because I've been always starting from
what it is that I need minimally to have
fun and to do the many fun things
that you can do with money. Um, uh,
I just multiply that by
20. If it, if it's over 20,
I don't worry anymore. And I, I,
thankfully I haven't worked for a while,
but if I looked at the
opportunities that boy,
if I did this and I put
these two companies together
and that I would have, uh,
something else.
If it's going to take away one of my
Mondays or Thursdays are going to take one
of the Times or many of the times I
can't pick up my kids from school,
etc. It's certainly a bad deal
no matter how much money or what,
what metric it is,
you know?
Definitely. Well, I mean the non
renewable resource being that time,
and I'd love to hear some details because
I'm grappling with some of
these issues and structuring.
Structuring is too formal a word,
but I had a very good 2016 and I think
it was in part because I had so much
slack in the system,
uh,
to do deep work and to enjoy
and savor certain things.
And 2017 because of the book launch few
months ago or six weeks ago has just
come crashing in with a lot of
inbound as most of which is noise.
So I'm thinking a lot about this.
What are some of the processes that you
love and could you walk us through maybe
a a Monday or Thursday that
comes to mind and what that,
what that looks like?
Yeah, and going from back
to front, um, I've been,
you know, writing a book in
my head now for the last two,
three years and I'm just scared of
putting it out there because you are then
caught in a vortex of your own
making, you know, Andy, right?
You get a publisher and then you,
you kind of,
you kind of sell them
the idea that you're,
you'll be there and they're kind of
saying that I'm going to do this,
but if I need you for the today show,
you're going to be there. Right? And,
and you're kind of, yeah, I'll try.
And so what about the fact
is that didn't really, one,
you never really want to
take on the whole, uh,
wait of proving yourself,
doing your thing and satisfying all
the cosponsors sponsors of your effort.
Right? And so there's the book launch
and there's right, and there's no end,
of course,
it,
it doesn't end that quickly because you
trick yourself into thinking this is six
months and then it will be okay.
But we know it's not because I just had,
for example, I got, uh, yesterday,
I just got my two copies of the,
um,
Chinese edition of my book of, uh, 1993.
So it takes a little bit.
That happened, right?
So, you know, I got the,
the Czech Republic edition of the
seven day weekend, about a month ago.
So this stuff just had
takes on a life of its own.
And then every time a
request comes for your time,
you, you stutter, you know,
you say, well, you know,
I don't really want to take this
slide and go this way and do news.
But on the other hand, you know, I kind
of have a responsibility to do that.
And it's, it's a little bit like
the little prince, you know, the,
the French book by science who could,
is sentenced to spirity,
which says that you are responsible
for everything that you captivate,
you know, and so you kind
of feel that, uh, war,
why did I write the book from first
place if I wrote it in the first place?
And it means that I should go to the
syndicated radio show because that'll sell
more books and more people will be
happy and I'll feel better on and on.
And you're caught with metrics
because somebody will say, so to him,
how many people listen to your
[inaudible] minion or this,
and I'm number 13 are on
number 11 and under six.
And people have caught you up in
their vortex of metrics as well.
And until something happens, you
retire, you die and so forth,
and it goes away because you're a non
contender from there on and then it's
perfectly all right.
And then you'll have to think,
who the hell is going to remember that
20 years from now or 40 years from now?
And and so, so you're left with the
issue of what am I doing this for? So my,
my answer to all of this, because if you
take this to its ultimate consequence,
you could easily be in a
situation where you say,
I do nothing anymore because nothing is
worth it because nothing will reply to
the issue of metrics.
Nothing will satisfy me enough.
Nothing is really worth it if we are
these useless specks of dust on the,
in the universe.
And so I don't,
I don't take it to that
Russian now because we are
100% of ourselves in terms of
importance at the same
time. Um, and so you,
you can be worried about the
state of nations and poverty and,
uh,
immigration policies.
But if there's a speck
of dust in your high,
you're going to spend the next hour
and a half only dealing with that.
There's nothing else of any importance
in the world while there's a speck in
your eye and your eyes watery.
And so what it meant by this is
that on Mondays and Thursdays,
let's say I stopped the thing, I wake
up and one of the first things I do is,
is a lounge in bed. Meaning I, uh, I,
I haven't had an alarm clock I think
for, for 15 or 20 years, but I,
I say I will not get out of bed.
And of course that doesn't last very long,
but the feeling is good. And then, um,
I'm with the kids as a fourth end and
suddenly they get into the van and mine,
they're, and suddenly
everything is quiet. Um,
in one second.
And then I start asking myself,
so what I wanted to do,
I, I could read the paper,
but I don't really want to read the paper.
And the news is this and that.
I could read that book, but now
I'm halfway there and you're stuck.
I think many times with the issue that
we keep ourselves busy and we have all of
these distractions and attractions and
things going at such a rate that when you
actually turn off all the noise and say,
which of these things where
I really want to do, um, you,
you have much more trouble
than you thought you did.
And so when we put that book out there
or as you did and you have requests and
you have opportunities,
you really just kind of measure the
opportunities of what to do against each
other. So you know, in
that, in that sense,
it's a bit like cafca again,
you know, definitely. Um, that,
that door's open just for you,
but you say, you know, what a,
is it better to go talk to these guys
in Denver or to do this thing in London?
You know,
but the real question was,
what the hell for am I doing either of
these? And I think you'll end up with the,
with the reply that the things
that you can look back on.
You said that was a good one,
two hours,
three hours of my life because I either
shared something, I learned something.
Um, I, it felt good. These are
all wonderful responses. I,
you know,
or you went to the baseball game,
you're done losing two hours of your life.
That's a wonderful way to spend those two
hours if you love baseball and or not.
And so, um, it,
it's not about nothingness or undoing
yourself or considering yourself worthless
and therefore it's not worth
doing anything. Um, and,
but it is especially about not comparing
the opportunities with each other and
rather compare them. What would
I do if I had the whole day off?
The best feeling I have in my,
in my time is never the
Monday and Thursday,
which I do love when I get up m and bed
thinking today I have nothing to do.
It is on that Tuesday or on that
Friday when I have something set,
a conference call or a visit or
something and that gets canceled.
That's my most wonderful moment is always
when I have stuff to do and somebody
cancels.
It has an enormous sense of relief no
matter how important it was or which I was
looking forward to. It said when somebody
cancels something, I feel elated,
you know? And so I think that
kind of answers a bit as well. No,
no it does. And I mean, I'd love to
uncover some of the,
some of the quirks I had.
Somebody asked me a question a few days
ago that I thought was a good question.
We'll find out. It may be, it may
fall flat, but he asked me, what are,
what are some of absurd things
that you like doing or love doing?
What are some absurd
things that you love doing?
Does anything come to mind for you?
When I asked that question,
um, I have, I have all these old,
old, old line habits. One of them
comes from Winston Churchill,
which is to sit in a
bathtub with a lit cigar.
I'm sure it'll pass a lot of
people's tests of absurdity. But, um,
so sometimes I'll say,
you know,
now I will do nothing and I
will sit in about for an hour,
hour and a half with it, with a very long
cigar and sync like Winston Churchill.
And I always remember this especially
well because Churchill was a guy who was
even in power and to an extent as happened
to Fdr as well when he had his polio
thing in Florida.
But I'm,
Winston Churchill would go off a bit
before Christmas and take a ship to Egypt
where he would go to the same
winter palace hotel in sir.
And he would spend 65 days there a
while he was running the country.
And so I think we,
we give ourselves an enormous amount
of importance and to our time.
And I think doing absurd things
interrelated to wasting time,
I think are a wonderful way to remind
ourselves that we're neither that
important or that nes,
her or none of that much happens when
you do absurd things with your time.
And I think purposely looking
like you're wasting it,
I think is in an absurdly
wonderful thing to do.
Do you know, people looking
from the outside in, uh,
many people will be very impressed with
your ability to experiment and to test
and to have failures, but also
have these successes in home runs.
Do you think about risk differently than
other people or how do you think about
risk?
I think that that word is a scary word
to a lot of people and they don't really
define it for themselves.
Um, and so they don't try,
but I'd just love to hear your
thoughts on risk or perceiving risk,
how you think about it.
Yeah.
When you, when you try and deconstruct
risk, I'd say there, there,
there's an objective metric
associated with risks.
So I'm going to start this business.
I'm going to take 32% of my
savings and I might lose it all.
So that's a kind of metric that I think
is less scary because you know that it's
32%, you know, that is, you
lose it, you're going to,
it's going to be trouble for some
time and then some restrictions, et.
But it is an outside metric which you
are willing to accept. If she'd say,
I'm going to take a plane and I know that
the statistical risk is zero comments,
zero,
zero far of this or that,
or it'd be coming late then and then
a hundred times smaller of the plane
falling and I'll,
I'll take that risk.
That bit I think scares people very
little even though they paid bring it up.
I think people use it very much was an
excuse because the other risk factor is
how will I look to myself,
to my spouse,
to my kids too,
my former business partners to micro.
Now how would I look if the
five flat fall flat on my face?
And I think that this element of risk
is the one that doesn't bother me almost
at all because I think it is
so ephemeral. You know, um,
you get a bad press or
you're getting a bad, uh,
opinion from neighbors or your wife has
dismayed that you actually did this.
I think all this goes away very
easily and relatively quickly.
It might take a few months. So she,
here's where all this goes away.
And it's not to say that it's worth
doing because if you do succeed,
then you will show them all your
running or rephrase or EOP happier.
Be gratified yourself even because
we know that a lot of these apparent
successes and apparent things that we
call home runs, there are also temporary,
right in that sense that you right,
you'll do something and the last mile
of everything you do is probably what's
going to count.
This is also an ironic
turn on life, which is that you go
there and you spend 20, 30 years today.
This today, today we had one of
our biggest billionaires in Brazil,
uh,
fall into jail.
He was in New York over the weekend and
he was arrested and is involved in the
corruption charge.
And he was the seventh richest man in
the world who was by far Brazil's a
richest person, is uh, 20,
30 years of an earning successes and
one success on top of the other were all
wonderful. And uh, he obviously
has a genius for business,
otherwise he wouldn't have gotten where
he got and he has his dark side as well
and so forth. So he got to this
point, I don't know him personally,
I've never met him,
but he got to this point where he was
this billionaire and he had this enormous
projects and he was doing
wonderful things. And he had a,
on the side you had hobbies
and restaurants and yachts
and doing things for poor
people and on and on and on and on. Now
he's in jail. I don't know for how long,
maybe maybe even not that long,
but the fact is that he has these hair
products company and was always very
proud of his hair. And you,
you know another guy who,
who has similar hair and he in jail,
the first thing they did was to
shave him bald. So you see now,
and what I meant to say was, what
is success for this guy? You know,
it was it the 34 years in which he had
yachts and planes and every president and
everybody would receive him and you
to wonderful things and so forth.
Or is it now so tainted by this last
image on his health that he will never
recover? You know what,
I'm, I'm no judgment at all.
I'm just saying that when
you think about this,
who I think about some of the people
who were presidents of Brazil,
some people who are prisons to the
u s who were there at 50 or 60,
and their life is over,
it's no longer success.
It keeps deteriorating as the,
as the years go by. You know,
you take someone like a,
like a planted who has an extraordinary
mind, did a lot of good things,
but they made a few enormous mistakes
with cigars and trainees that you will
never recover from. And so what,
what is success in that passage?
I meant what I meant to say was that your
home runs and the businesses you built
in the menu haven't framed it is all very,
very fragile and it's probably going to
be measured with how you handle yourself
in a few very few, uh, uh,
decisive moments in your life.
And, or in the end, you know,
the last few things you did are terribly
important compared to what you did
before. And, uh, or this
guy, I could forget his name.
Pastorius for pistol Pistorious
in South Africa. Yeah.
It's tremendous guy,
et cetera.
Until you kill your girlfriend
and then suddenly the,
all those other successes don't,
don't sit very well.
Now can you do your things,
have your successes, build
up your metrics, et Cetera,
and then retire and sit tight
for 20, 30 years, enjoying,
etc. Probably the feeling inside is that
slow your worlds are deteriorating in
the sense that your friends are dying,
the press no longer interested in
you and you become, uh, uh, has been,
who still has a few things to,
to nail up on the wall or remember
jaded photographs of you with someone.
Very important,
you know?
And so I think that the success factor
and this metric of how you measure
yourself is very,
very fragile.
And when we stick to it, we stick to
something that, uh, won't be there.
When we try to hold it in our hands,
it has to be held a bit like a bird,
you know, as you press it a
little bit too hard at that.
How do you think of success for
yourself then in place of leaning on or
depending on the Ephemera and all of
these things that can be taken away so
easily, uh, or destroyed
so easily. How do you,
how do you feel at peace with yourself
or feel successful? What, what,
how do you,
what Lens do you use for that?
I try to,
I try to exchange these lenses of past
and future for living in the present,
which is the only very difficult
thing to do. We talk about it,
but nobody knows how to
do it. MMM. You know,
the James Taylor is set in
a song because that, uh,
the meaning of life is to enjoy the
passing of time and try their best at the
time is by far the hardest
thing we can ever do in.
We take your thought process.
We are almost constantly living
in the past or in the future.
And so success to me is always making
sure that this passing of time is
worthwhile.
That's his past.
He knew his time right now that I'm not
exchanging it for a hole in the future.
I'm not exchanging for um,
something I got or had in the past and
that you're always kind of ready two
survivor to withstand
through the use of this wisdom
of, of present time, of which I'm,
I'm very far still from it, but I just
keep hammering it into my own head.
This passing of time, if this, uh,
podcast and conversation with you was
worth it because it made me think because
it was saw tool for a sense so far,
um,
that that is success and that can
never be taken away no matter what.
Tomorrow I don't have the money or I
don't have this sort of things go wrong,
God forbid, uh, with, with people. Uh,
the fact is that that
one hour or two hours,
which was spent in the broadcast thinking
about licensing and exchanging that,
that one was definitely worthwhile and
successful and no one can no longer be
taken away from you because it's not
part and when it becomes part of your
history or your past is just building
blocks of time that were spent.
You know, I had an interesting
situation with for a time I was,
I was buying much more wine than I
should have because I was kind of,
I got into the collector's mode about 25,
30 years ago.
And so I kept buying at auctions
and of course you get into this,
uh,
thing where you need to have,
have that 1959 or otherwise and so forth.
And so you'll go crazy at auction,
you overpay and so forth. And uh,
and one of these days I, Hey,
I had a friend over and I,
I opened one of these wonderful
wines that were extraordinary,
extraordinary year and I,
I'll be at Ford and so forth.
And this stuff can't be used for
vinegar was completely spoiled.
It was always completely
spot when I bought it.
It was is already worth
nothing whatsoever.
And I always thought it was an
interesting collection because you,
you buy all of this wine that you have
all kinds of expectations from and you're
learning to say,
you know,
this has pencil shavings and a bit of
mineral that and some marigolds flower in
the taste and so far.
But you know,
there's an enormous amount of bullshit
in what you're doing and why you're doing
it and so forth.
But the interesting part is that once
you consume your collectible by drinking
the wine, you're left always
with 20 cents of glass, which is,
and so it's just a way of saying
that this whole process of,
of wine is it good is a
good comparison because, um,
one guy told me a few Kitsune what,
what,
what gets you into your,
your seller and makes you
take a bottle of wine,
which you paid $100 for is now worth
$1,000 and drink this and be left with a
little bit of glass because you end up
probably not even having the courage to
drink this wine that now is so,
uh, valuable, et Cetera, et cetera.
But I, I've always answered
that in the following way.
If one day I look at my seller and I do
now and it's about half empty or more,
it is now about half empty.
And I think that every time I
pulled one of those bottles,
it was because I was with friends
or because I was feeling good over.
This was a great time.
This must've been a good life.
Looking at those empty holes,
you know? And so that's,
I think with everything else,
if,
if you're using that time and you
at the end of it, you say, boy,
that was a good two hours of this
was worth it, then success is,
is certainly guaranteed.
How did you stop,
uh,
the collection of wine when you were
getting caught up in these auctions and so
on? What was the pattern
interrupt or the, the,
the conversation or the moment when
you decided to, to stop doing that?
I actually remember it very well.
It was very specific.
I went to Thailand and,
um, and in Thailand I met,
this guy was actually Chinese,
but he was in Thailand and he was a
tomato farmer and he had a mini mills.
He had these many steel mills, steel
mills, and he was a magnet and he'd made,
it was a real tycoon. He'd made
enormous amounts of money is set aside.
And we were, we went to have
dinner with this guy and, um,
he was smoking all through the
dinner. And I asked him, you know,
how many cigarettes? He smokes
a day or packs. And he said, no,
I light one in bed.
And then I lied all the
cigarettes with another cigarette.
That's why I never did. I never did the
math on that, but it can't be very good.
But anyway,
so he would,
he would eat with one hand and he would
puff with the other and at no moment to
do stop smoking. And, um,
then we started talking about,
he said that he's has a bit of an
obsession for things and so forth.
The city collects things. I said,
what do you collect? And he said,
I collect Mercedes cars.
And so you have a lot of these. And
he said, yeah, I have a lot of these.
I have 111 warehouses,
Mercedes.
And he said,
and I have the mercy of
the first Mercedes of 1896,
which is a steam Mercedes.
And I have all the Mercedes in
between. And I said, what do you mean?
Every time there is a Mercedes that
comes out every year they come out with
let's say six models that buy one of each.
And when Mercedes needed,
uh,
Himmler's car and the car
that Hitler went into Paris,
I lent them the car because I have
the car. Okay. And so I was there,
obviously stunned at this conversation
and all this smoking and I was like,
Jesus,
what a little do I know about interesting
people are free to people around the
world. And then I, uh, at one
point I said, well, but uh,
so what do you, you just keep on
collecting? He says that instead of,
then of course I have to go,
I have to go in a few days I'm going
to an auction because there are several
Mercedes there, there were a total
of 12 Mercedes, which I don't have.
And I said to him, now, how much
does it bother? Instead of, Oh,
I keeps me awake many nights he said,
and I keep going at it and
I'm going crazy and I work at,
I need to have these talk more sense. And
at that moment I stopped buying anyone.
Yeah.
I don't think I brought a wife since.
My God, what a story. Uh, we, we
could go for a very long time.
I want to be respectful of your time.
There's so many things that I'd
love to touch on like Lumiar and,
and many other areas.
But tell me what you think of this.
We could do a few rapid fire questions
and then maybe if you enjoyed this and
everyone enjoys it, which I think they
will, we could consider maybe doing,
I'll follow up at some point.
Uh,
I'm certainly happy to stay on and talk
about anything you'd like, but I'd,
I'd love to ask maybe a few rapid fire
questions and then lead people to what
you're up to now and where they can,
they can find you if that,
if that sounds like a plan,
but I know we've been on for
recording now close two hours. So
if, if, if that works for you, we
could, we could take that approach,
but I'm certainly happy to touch on
anything that you'd like to talk about.
No, let's do that. And
you're, I'm assuming you want
rapid fire applies as well,
which is not my
special,
no,
the rapid fire questions really just
means that I have to stop asking multipart
questions with 17 commas.
So your answer can be as,
as long as you'd like.
So I will just keep my questions short.
Uh, and I'm certainly not
in any rush. Uh, this, uh,
number one is what books have
you re-read the most yourself?
Oh, very. Always go
back to, um, two books,
one by Carl Young and,
and this whole issue of
collective unconscious,
which is to me a big issue because you
either are able to touch in and touch and
get involved somehow in this collective
unconscious or you're doing things which
are very much on your own and,
and not significant in a sense that
they're trailblazing, et cetera.
They're, they're just not connected
to the world as they should be.
And another one I keep,
I keep going back to is very interesting
because I come from a Jewish family,
even though nobody was,
was religious. There's a,
there's a cultural unethical issue there,
but I only found out actually I was
maybe 10 years ago and, um, uh,
even though I have suspicious of it,
but the one that I read every once in a
while I pick up because it's around the
house. And because my wife has a
bit more religious is, is the Bible,
but it was a wonderful set of stories,
philosophy, et cetera. And I read it
much like you would read Shakespeare,
you know, and it's just extraordinary
because it has everything.
Shakespeare has all of the human traits.
If you look somewhere,
you will find it either in King Lear and
have litter and buck methods there. And,
uh,
and the,
the vibe was very interesting
book to keep going back to,
to,
to get a glimpse of humanity.
Do you have any favorite
documentaries or movies?
Yeah, my favorite documentary is
one called up. Are you seeing that?
I have, yes. It's fantastic.
And, uh, and for, for the
people listening to us, it's,
it's a Guy Michael apted who were in
1964 decided to follow about a dozen,
actually more kids from very different
backgrounds and from in the UK and some
in orphanages and some very well off to
try and establish how much people are
stuck to their,
um,
to their context,
to their social context.
And so when it's very interesting because
he follows them every seven years,
right? So it's seven, 14, 2128 and
so forth until 56, which was the one.
And it's quite an extraordinary
way to look at humanity and see,
can people really escape their
social constraints and their initial,
um, lay of life, you know,
and in general is the assumption is that
they cannot and that great sense that
bares itself out. Note Tim in the sense
that it doesn't look like you can,
you can stray that far from
the path on average. No.
Yeah, it's, I think they
revisited them what,
every five years or something like that.
Seven, seven I'm sorry. That's right.
Because it was seven up and then it
became the seven up series. Uh, yeah,
all multiples of seven. But it's the
same people, which is extraordinary.
You seen someone who's seven was
14, it was 21 was 28. It was not 56.
And their dreams and their hopes and what
they were actually able to do and how
close they in these seven year periods,
how close they have stayed too.
They're calling a parent calling
in life before they were born.
It's an incredible situation.
Yeah, it's a, this is, this
is the documentary series.
It's come up three or three or four times.
Uh,
I'd never heard of it before interviewing
a number of people on the podcast.
So that was actually introduced to the
series through the podcast as well.
It's wonderful. And, uh, just just
on that tone tend to say that,
you know, you're, you're in a country
that says, boy, anybody can do anything.
You May, anybody can be anything. Don't
let anybody stand in your way. You can be,
et cetera. But it's not really
true at all. This is I think,
a very interesting take on this
documentary and on the American dream,
you know, even what's what's happening
today in the u s has a reaction to this.
So where the fuck is my American dream
that was promised to me, you know,
but the fact is that you're promising
classroom of kids and as a valid the
Taurian and speaking
at conferences and uh,
egging them on at Mbas,
the fact is that you cannot,
you know, humanity has a programmer
and long story in a very,
very long proof that I'm in general,
your chance of changing walks of life,
changing class,
changing path from what,
for the context which you were started
with is a very, very rare situation.
And that very,
very rare situation makes for
wonderful books and speeches and films.
But it only makes for these wonderful,
uh,
for this wonderful entertainment
because it's so, so rarely true.
Now is that very dismal and disappointing
to look at and say, boy, you know,
now that you've put this in my face
now I'm not going to try anything.
It's not even worth it.
No,
it's just to remember that in the passing
of time of the station of life that
was,
that was created or available to you and
your context there could be and should
be a wonderful life.
The wonderful life is in rising all
the time until you're at the top.
There's nothing that's particularly
interesting at the top.
It just seems absolutely wonderful.
When you're looking at it from the bottom,
what would you say, for instance,
if you were teaching again,
but instead of at the MBA program at Mit,
you were teaching a ninth grade class
in some economically disadvantaged area,
let's just say,
could be the ghetto in Chicago,
could be any number of places in the u s
w what would you teach in that ninth or
10th grade class to help them improve the
odds of not remaining in their current
cycle?
And I have, you know, we obviously you,
you talk way too much, so we haven't
had time to talk about education,
which I'd love to as
well. But of course, I've,
I've taken, let's say
the last 10, 12 years,
I've taken all of this effort and this
risk taking what I learned before and
taking it to the world of
education. And, but, uh, I spent,
uh,
the first,
the first few years of that teaching
six year olds in a public school and
heavily just disadvantaged bandage kids
and so forth. So it was, it was fun to do.
Um, what I, what I tried to
do most with them was to,
um,
get them to realize the magic of the
accumulated wisdom of human kind.
And that poking at this magic of
what we've been able to do and think,
and all this time,
all the rest will take care of itself.
And so if I sit there and say,
you can do this,
you can find the strength within you.
It is possible.
You can do anything you want. You
can be anything you want. I don't,
I don't believe in that. And so I kept
showing them things like I would say,
I remember one day it was stepping
outside of there. I said, let's,
I'm going to teach you the special
relativity theory of Einstein.
So it's like you're here with me
in this little village, right?
Right now you look up and I say, how
long would it take you to go to the moon?
And so they'd say this and
that and rockets and all
what it was and promoted to
the next and on and on and
to Neptune and ranch. Great.
And then to the edge of the universe.
And then there's the, their,
their mind is going all
over the place of course.
And we're trying to think this
through together. And I said,
if you come to the end of the world,
the end of the universe and there were
a little quicker and now you've traveled
for thousands and thousands and thousands
of years in your rocket ship and so
forth. And now according
to this man, Mr Einstein,
you opened this little curtain
at the end of the universe.
Where would you be the answer?
[inaudible] in,
in following the theory. And people
will know, this will tell you,
you will be in this
little village right here.
Well was looking up into
the sky and these crazy,
crazy concepts which are true and
which are about us. And to say that he,
we are up here in the mountains,
so time here moves a little quicker than
it does at beach level and so that you
have exact twins who were
born and one is on the beach.
One is an amount by the end of
90 years when they meet again,
the one in the mountain will be older,
slightly older.
This kind of stuff is to me,
what unlocks the whole possibility
for people to think, boy,
I can be anything,
do anything.
It's harder because they're looking at
the magical response of what life looks
like,
what we've learned all along to this date,
and that is the key that
they can eventually use to
free themselves. Or is it,
if you could have a gigantic billboard
anywhere and actually now I think a
billboards are there.
No billboards in Sao Paulo.
I feel like that's one of a few cities
that has perhaps made the billboards
illegal. But that's, that's an aside. The,
the, the metaphorical question is if you,
if you could have one gigantic
billboard anywhere with anything on it,
in other words, just getting a short
message out to millions of people,
what would you put on that billboard?
No,
that's enough.
People pay attention to, to
now so many other issues, uh,
go away because I think so
much of everything we do
is taken up by the past and
the future.
And so little of our successes there that
remembering,
uh, that you're now in a bus, you're not
on a train, you're not going somewhere,
you don't want,
you're not,
this is the stuff that I think falls short
all the time and somehow it does have
a lot of restrictions on,
on billboards and it's expensive and
it takes authorizations and Soho.
So that helps.
But some of us,
so many other visual problems now we
have a new Trump like mayor who is going
around and uh,
covering up all of the spray
paints of the was graffiti artists.
That's the newest,
well, I think this is a
good place to, to wrap up.
And do you have any,
and I'll ask you where people can find
more about you and certainly put that in
the show notes as well, but do you have
any ask or request for my audience,
the people listening, any or any last
parting words that you'd like to share?
Yeah, I'd say that, you know, again, when
I think about, you know, why, why would I,
uh,
sit with you and a to our podcast,
why would I have a few people that I
wanted to talk to and that during this
little podcast episode of my own,
um,
it's all to do with, and
essentially of course, it's all a,
is it songful,
is it insightful for myself?
And therefore it's always very self
serving and very and very narrow,
let's say. But on the other hand, my,
my very generic wishes always a people
will be able to take a little something
out of it, which has an insight into
something that was already there.
Not that we created in this conversation,
but to someone takes on a little act of
courage in either giving more freedom to
people who were with them or
for them or their kids or their,
anything that's around.
And I think that it's terribly gratifying
to do just these very small leaps of
faith in these very small movements in
the direction of what seems like risk
and, uh, and is never a risk
because it's never a metric issue.
It's just getting past your own misgivings
about doing something new and that
that would be my hope that people take
this little leap of fancy or leap of
faith and finally decide to
make a change on constraints,
on restrictions that they either have or
that they need to fight against or they
need to remove other people from and
find that that's a hell of a lot more
liberating than it sounds
car do. I really appreciate you taking
the time. This was extremely fun for me.
And, uh, I've,
I've known you only through
video and texts up to this point.
So this was a unique opportunity for me.
So number one.
Thank you for taking the time and for
those people listening I will put links to
everything that was mentioned,
books and podcasts and otherwise
in the show notes as per usual,
you
can
find
those@timdotblogslashpodcastorfourhourworkweek.com
forward
slash
podcast you can say
hello and you should too.
Ricardo at Ricardo Semler and
let's lead wise on Twitter.
Facebook is let's lead wise and Linkedin
is Ricardo Semler and until next time,
as always, thank you for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before
you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoyed,
this episode is brought
to you by Wealthfront.
Wealthfront is the future of advice.
They
become incredibly popular among my
friends in silicon valley and across the
country because they provide the same
high end financial advice that the best
private wealth managers
delivered to the ultra wealthy.
But for any account size and at a
fraction of the cost. For instance,
they monitor your portfolio every day
across more than it doesn't asset classes
to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses. Now,
would you do the same? Are you
doing the same? Probably not.
And the powers in the software wealth
front now manages more than $4 billion in
assets,
which is up from around 2.5 billion.
When they started
advertising on this podcast,
they're growing incredibly quickly. Unlike
old fashioned private wealth managers,
wealth front is powered
by innovative technology,
making it the most tax efficient,
low cost, hassle free way to invest.
They don't have bloated sales
teams or retail locations,
so they can deliver all of this
sophisticated financial advice and these
services at a fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor.
So at the very least, go
to wealthfront.com forward
slash Tim and take it.
They're free risk assessment survey.
It only takes a couple of
minutes and Wealthfront.
We'll recommend a personalized portfolio
of investments. In other words,
they'll tell you exactly where
they would put your money.
So even if you don't use their service,
you have a huge leg up and you have
additional information for making good
decisions.
They use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make,
but should go to wealthfront.com forward
slash Tim to get your first 15 came
managed for free or just
to get more details,
check out wealthfront.com forward slash
Tim this episode is brought to you by
freshbooks.
Freshbooks is now the number one cloud
accounting software designed exclusively
for self employed professionals and
used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices, track
your time, and get paid fast,
which basically describes the core needs
of most entrepreneurs and freelancers.
The product was recently relaunched
and rebuilt from the ground up,
focusing on simplicity and speed.
It's an awesome service and many
have you recommended it to me,
which is how they came to be a sponsor.
Now I can't cover all of the many,
many features.
But for example,
you can take pictures of receipts on your
phone using freshbooks ios mobile app,
or connect your bank account or credit
card to fresh books and watch your
expenses automatically import
into your account every day.
And if you have any questions whatsoever,
a real live person answers in less than
three rings to help you with all of your
needs. So to claim your 30
day unrestricted free trial,
that means no credit card needed and see
how the all new fresh books can change
your freelancing game.
Go to freshbooks.com forward slash
Tim and enter Tim Tim in the,
how did you hear about us section?
That is freshbooks.com forward
slash Tim and then Tim Tim in the,
how did you hear about us?
Section.